opportunity to enhance the videos so
that we could get a better look the
other thing that we have had an
opportunity to do is to view some of the
physical evidence the Chevrolet
Trailblazer was a vehicle that was in
the line at Wendy's on the night of this
incident and it received a shot from
officer Roth's gun we've had an
opportunity along with the GBI now to
view that Trailblazer my office has had
an opportunity to inspect the crime
scene we have conducted a canvass of the
area we started our investigation at
about 1:15 a.m. on Saturday morning and
we have been working on this case
around-the-clock since that time go to
the next level we have spent some time
examining the Taser evidence in this
case we've actually examined and
possessed the two tasers that were used
we have also had an opportunity to
examine the Taser logs that are prepared
as the tasers are used and we have also
consulted with a Taser expert from the
company that manufactures the tasers we
receive a preliminary medical autopsy
we've received the preliminary
ballistics report and in reaching our
conclusions today we have worked with
both the Georgia Bureau of Investigation
as well as the Atlanta Police Department
this will be the fourth time that we
have asked that arrest warrants are
issued in a case before an indictment
this lists the other three cases that we
were involved with where an arrest
warrant was issued prior to indictment
unfortunately this marks the 40th
prosecution of police officers for
misconduct here in our county and this
is the ninth time that we've prosecuted
a homicide case committed by a police
officer eight of those cases involved
black males and one of those cases
involved a black female so in reaching
our decision there were some
considerations that we considered
important and one of the things that we
noted from our evaluation was that mr.
Brooks on the night of this incident was
calm he was cordial and really displayed
a cooperative nature secondly even
though mr. Brooks was slightly impaired
his demeanor during this incident was
almost jovial also we noted that he
received many instructions from the
Atlanta officers and he was asked many
questions some of the questions he was
asked repeatedly but for 41 minutes and
17 seconds
he followed our instruction he answered
the questions the fourth thing we noted
is that mr. Brooks was never informed
that he was under arrest for driving
under the influence and this is a
requirement of the Atlanta Police
Department when one is charged with the
DUI the Atlanta Police Department's own
procedures require that that person is
informed immediately that they are under
arrest and then he was grabbed from the
rear by officer Roth who made an attempt
to physically restrain him after the 41
minute and 17 second discussion we
concluded and considered it as one of
our
important considerations that mr. Brooks
never presented himself as a threat at
the very beginning he was peacefully
sleeping in his car after he was
awakened by the officer he was
cooperative and he was directed to move
his car to another location he calmly
moved his car mr. Brooks was asked
whether or not he had a weapon he
indicated that he did not without any
resistance he passed his driver's
license to the officers and the officers
then asked mr. Brooks whether or not he
would consent to a pat-down or a body
search and mr. Brooks allowed them to
search him and the search yielded no
weapon we found that it was of interest
that when the officers patted mr. Brooks
down they noticed there was a bulge in
his pants
they did not pull that item out of his
pocket they took mr. Brooks is word that
that bulge represented a number of
dollar bills but mr. Brooks never
displayed any aggressive behavior
behavior during the seventy 41 minutes
and 17 seconds now this is a another
important consideration that we
discovered as we evaluated this case
once mr. Brooks was shot there is an
Atlanta policy that requires that the
officers have to provide timely medical
attention to mr. Brooks are to anyone
who is injured but after mr. Brooks was
shot for some period of 2 minutes and 12
seconds there was no medical attention
applied to mr. Brooks but when we
examine the videotape and in our
discussions with witnesses what we
discovered is during the two
in 12 seconds that officer Roth actually
kicked mr. Brooks while he laid on the
ground while he was there fighting for
his life secondly from the videotape we
were able to see that the other officer
officer Brosnan actually stood on mr.
Brooks's shoulders while he was there
struggling for his life we were able to
conclude that based on the way that
these officers conducted themselves
while mr. Brooks was lying there that
the demeanor of the officers immediately
after the shooting did not reflect any
fear or danger of mr. Brooks but their
actions really reflected other kinds of
emotions so as we are drawing our legal
conclusion in this case we were led by
the two foundational cases in this
matter
one being Tennessee versus garner and
what that case points out is when an
officer is pursuing a fleeing suspect
that the officer may not use deadly
force to prevent escape unless the
officer has probable cause to believe
that the suspect poses an immediate
threat of death or of serious physical
injury to that officer the next
foundational case that we used in our
analysis as Graham versus Connor which
says that this test is based upon that
of a reasonable officer on the scene and
not the individual officer but a
reasonable officer on the scene we've
concluded at the time mr. Brooks was
shot that he did not pose an immediate
threat of death or serious physical
injury to the
officer or officers if you would get the
photograph the yeah the tape
this is the first photograph that we
were able to clean this kind of quickly
to see if you can get a straight
of what this photograph illustrates is
the explain that officer rock at this
point was filing the paper and this is
mr. Brooks who was firing a Taser as
well but I don't know if you can see it
clearly the prongs from the table
the Taser were actually fired above
officer Ross here might be you also look
at the position of officer law in mr.
Brooks that they are here next to this
red automobile if we look at the next
photograph
if we look at the next photograph will
see that the positions of both parties
they've changed mr. Brooks has now moved
away from his original position and we
estimate the distance is probably about
12 feet and officer Roth has moved about
10 feet from the position in what is our
exhibit number one this second video our
second stele shows the the very instance
that the shot was fired into the back of
mr. Brooks and we have also calculated
the distance and the distance that they
are part at that time was 18 feet 3
inches at the time that this shot was
fired so based upon that information we
have concluded that mr. Brooks was
running away at the time that the shot
was fired mr. Brooks was shot twice in
the back one of the shots was the sinner
shot to the back that penetrated his
heart and it was done by a 9-millimeter
Glock now one of the things that we also
relied upon in our conclusion is
something that is called under the law
or referred to as an excited utterance
and that's when someone makes a an
immediate statement and because it is
made without the ability to consult with
counsel or to think about it under the
law of an excited utterance is
considered as highly reliable and at the
time that the shot was fired the
utterance made by officer Roth was oh I
got it that was the statement that was
made at that time the we also noted that
officer rah
was firing a Taser at mr. Brooks the
city of Atlanta SOPs in fact prohibit
officers from firing tasers at someone
who is running away so the city of
Atlanta says you cannot even fire a
Taser at someone who is running away so
you certainly can't fire a gun a handgun
at someone who is running away so in
addition to our findings as many of you
all already know that the Atlanta mayor
mayor Keisha bottoms and the police
department concluded that Officer RAAF's
actions were excessive and in violation
of APD's SOP as an SOP I believe it's
4.1.1 and after their analysis that the
actions were excessive officer Roth was
fired
we have also concluded that Roth was
aware that the Taser and Brooks's
possession that it was fired twice and
once it's fired twice it presented no
danger to him are there any other
persons now we have had something quite
remarkable to happen in this case and it
involves the testimony of the other
officer Devon Brosnan because officer
Brosnan has now become a state's witness
he has decided to testify on behalf of
the state in this case what he has said
to us that is within a matter of days he
plans to make a statement regarding the
culpability of officer Roth but he
indicated that he is not psychologically
willing to give that statement today
officer Brosnan however has admitted
that he was in fact standing on mr.
Brooks's body immediately after the
shooting so these are the charges that
we have had filed a day signed by one of
our Superior Court judges these are the
11 charges against officer Roth the
first charge is felony murder
this is a death that is as a result of a
underlying felony and in this case the
underlying felony is aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon and the possible
sentences for a felony murder conviction
would be life life without parole or the
death penalty now he's also charged by
in in the arrest warrant with aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon and this is
a account charging him for the shooting
of mr. Brooks and the possible sentence
for aggravated assault is 1 to 20 years
the second of the third aggravated
assault account is father shooting
towards are in the direction of mr.
Melvin Evans mr. Evans was the person
who seated in the car did we have the
picture of his video
and if you would point out this
automobile is the place that mr. Evans
and his two companions were driving and
a shot was fired and I believe we've
also got a photo of the shot that ended
up in the vehicle I think you got it
stand it up and so with count 4 against
miss officer ruff it charges him with
aggravated assault for firing the weapon
in or in the direction of Danielle
Killians who was in the passenger side
of the drop front seat of the car on
next slide
count 5 r is the Nagre vated assault
charge and this was they charge for
shooting towards or in the direction of
Michael Perkins mr. Perkins were seated
in the rear of this same vehicle at that
time there's a charge for criminal
damage for shooting into that vehicle
also officer Roth is charged with seven
violations of office each one of those
carries a 1 to 5 sentence these are
violations of his oath of office for the
city of Atlanta arresting mr. Brooks for
the DUI without immediately informing
him of the arrests shooting a Taser at
mr. Brooks while he was running away
which again is a violation of Atlanta's
own SOP thirdly excessive force when
shooting a firearm at mr. Brooks and
number 4 is the failure to render timely
medical aid those are the four
violations of both the 8th is for
kicking mr. Brooks and the possible
sentence for kicking mr. Brooks
is from 1 to 20 years and we actually
have a photograph of the
and if you would go to the next and
these are the charges for officer
Brosnan and their total of three charges
and the first charge is for aggravated
assault and this is for standing or
stepping on mr. Brooks's shoulder and
the possible sentence for this crime is
one to twenty years and this is a
photograph of officer Brosnan who you
can see to the right and at the time of
the photograph he is standing on the
body of mr. Brooks and as I've indicated
earlier in our conversations with mr.
with officer Brosnan he has admitted
that he stood on the body of mr. Brooks
he said he believes that he was standing
on mr. Brooks's arm but that is what the
photograph shows we've also charged him
with additionally to violations of oath
one is far the standing on the shoulder
that is an unauthorized weaponless
control technique which the city of
Atlanta prohibits and the second
violation of oath was father a failure
to render timely medical aid to to mr.
Brooks
so the arrest warrants have already been
signed we are asking officer Roth and
officer Breslin to surrender themselves
by 6:00 p.m. on the morrow we are
because officer
Brosnan is now becoming a cooperating
witness father
they we are asking the court to grant a
bond of $50,000 and to allow mr. officer
Brosnan to sign that bond as I indicated
that he would become one of the first
police officers to actually indicate
that he is willing to testify against
someone in his own department as for
officer ruff the person who fired the
two bullets we are asking we're
recommending no bond for officer Ralph
if he is given a bond that would be done
by one of our Superior Court judges but
because of the severity of his act and
then following up that act with kicking
mr. Brooks we are asking that he not be
granted a bond I think that's it I do
want to ask mr. Shawn Williams mr.
Williams who represents Melvin Evans who
was driving the vehicle from Memphis I
have already apologized to mr. Evans on
behalf of the people of Fulton County in
the city of Atlanta
he was only down here for a short while
and it's really unfortunate that he was
his vehicle was fired upon that night
Shawn Thank You mr. Howard I first want
to on behalf of all three of my clients
who not only witnessed this horrific and
tragic killing of this young man I want
to offer the condolences from them to
the ratio Brooks family and particularly
his daughter it has been very difficult
for each one of my clients because they
witnessed it and they themselves have a
lot of emotion on what they saw and what
they was a part of I'm voluntarily
I want to thank Paul Howard personally
and commend him I've been doing these
type of cases across this nation and mr.
Harris one of the few
prosecutors who will actually go on the
line to even investigate something like
this as serious as this and to do it in
a way that I believe makes the city
proud as I'm a resident of this great
city and as he said with greatness come
responsibility the city of Atlanta is a
great city and I wanted to apologize to
my clients themselves but they came to
from Memphis and witnessed this they're
not gonna give statements here today but
I will confirm to you that they have met
with the Georgia Bureau of Investigation
provided them statements as well as
information to support what you saw
presented today by Paul Howard it
confirms that at no time was mr. Brooks
ever a threat to anyone including the
officers in that Wendy's parking lot
my clients statements confirm that mr.
Brooks was running his back was turned
and was never a threat to anybody the
only threat that arose is when officer
pulled out had done
two of those bullets entered mr. ray
shards bricks body killing him one of
those bullets entered my clients vehicle
almost killing them we could be here
talking about four murders and for that
my clients have suffered a lot but
nothing compared to what this family has
and with that said my clients are here
to join the fight of justice to provide
any assistance to this family as well as
to the 14 County District Attorney's
Office as well as the GBI and they look
forward to an opportunity where they
have justice is served and I want you to
know that they were fearful for their
lives
I'm that bullet came very close to them
and mr. Brooks his body laid less than
ten feet from their vehicle and keep in
mind this was in a crowded
Wendy's drive-through parking lot and
when you take the actions of
reasonableness as mr. Howard said
reasonableness never has a deadly weapon
being fired when you have innocent
bystanders like my client standing all
of those things as well as the fact that
mr. Brooks was not a threat to any
officer that night should have gone into
play but it didn't and I hope and pray
the with this action by a Fulton County
District Attorney's Office as well as
the actions by mayor bottoms and the
task force that we don't have to have
any more press conferences like this any
time soon thank you mr. Howard and
ladies and gentlemen mrs. Miller who is
the wife of Rashard Brooks is here today
I think her attorney Chris Stewart is
going to speak in her stead
good evening I'm Chris Stewart I'm a lot
partner Justin Miller Tamika is not in a
position to speak right now she wasn't
aware of all of this information just
like we weren't aware just like I don't
believe the nation was aware of all of
this that the shot happened after the
deployment of the Taser where he started
running again that you were kicked
another human being after you just put
two bullets in his back but even in dark
times like this you have to try and see
the light and the positivity of this
situation is the courageousness of
officer Brosnan to step forward and say
what happened was wrong it is officers
like that who changed policing and I
know he'll probably catch all kind of
problems and hate and things like that
but if the courageousness of those type
of officers that we love and support is
to courageousness of district attorney's
that are going to do their job and we
were willing to accept whatever the
findings were the best why people elect
you do your job that's why you become a
police officer do what's right so it's
not a day of joy watching the charges
and what's going to happen to this
officer because it shouldn't happen so
it's heartbreaking but it is an attempt
to redefine justice because like I said
before we don't have any idea what it is
anymore in this world and if this is
what justice is gonna start looking like
officers stepping forward to stop other
officers coming forward and hoping try
and get a family who now has their
father gone justice that we support it
and thank everybody out there who is
supporting this family and trying to
change the world of policing for the
better
for everybody
all right I am going to try to take a
few questions I wanted to I promised
miss Miller that I would get a chance to
spend a little time with her before they
had to leave it is a very unfortunate
situation for her and so I'll take a few
questions at this time we have as I
indicated earlier we've had about 40 of
these cases that we've prosecuted and I
don't remember a circumstance where
we've had an officer particularly in a
case this important to step forward and
say that they would cooperate with the
state so we're really appreciative of
officer Brosnan hopefully that will mean
that this matter can be resolved in a
much quicker manner but we certainly
appreciate his courage in standing up
and taking that step
[Music]
I don't I don't think I understood your
question but if it has something to do
the election this is what I'd say let's
deal with mr. Brooks today we can deal
with the election tomorrow is that all
right we spoke with him on last night
and we spoke to him again today and
sometime today he made the decision that
he would serve as a cooperating witness
[Music]
well he initially told us that he
thought that it was the situation was
well in hand and the situation was calm
but he was not an experienced DUI law
investigator so that's why he called
officer Roth in he has indicated to us
that he was somewhat surprised that it
accelerated into an actual arrest
because he thought that the situation
might have been resolved before then so
when he then decided to describe what
happened
once the wrastling took place on the
ground
you could tell he became a lot more
emotional and that's when he said to us
that he needed some additional time to
explain to us his feelings about the
shooting that took place off immediately
afterwards
he did tell us that he approached the
body afterwards and he admitted that he
did in fact as he described it stand on
the arm of mr. Brooks we asked why did
he stand on his arm and he said
something to the fact that he really
didn't know what was going on and he was
trying to ensure that mr. Brooks did not
have a weapon and you know we found that
kind of strange because mr. Brooks had
already displayed to them the
that he did not have a weapon well this
is what I would say we have been working
diligently to prepare those cases but
this case has something that meaning the
others don't have number one we've got
videotape the we don't have body cams we
don't have dash cams and so we have
spent an inordinate amount of time and
large sums of money trying to recreate
crime scenes we are not allowed the
police officers will not give us
statements and that's why we're very
surprised and really almost shocked that
Brosnan has come forward because in our
other cases we do not get statements to
assist us from the officers involved one
of the things that I'm hoping that we
will pass not only in our state but in
the entire country is that I think we
need to change the law I believe that
prosecutors should be allowed to indict
cases directly without a grand jury when
they involve police shootings and the
question that you ask me I would say to
those folks that are waiting if I had
the authority to sign the indictments I
would sign in the day and I'm hoping you
know our legislature is in session if
you really want to do something to
improve police misconduct why don't you
give district attorneys the right to
proceed with the case without waiting
for a grand jury and that's particularly
important now during the virus is
because it looks like right now we want
convene a grand jury in Fulton County
until October that's a long time I wish
that we could do it today
[Music]
we sometimes we do and sometimes we
don't like them well we didn't need it
because the as we pointed out the
evidence was available we could move
forward without getting the reports from
the GBI and we've been working with the
GBI in fact today we work together with
the automobile that we talked about so
it was a different circumstance because
once you get the videotape then we've
had eight of them I believed in this
case it places the case on a different
level of being investigated well that's
just one of the things I mean as we said
before that the whole casual
conversation the fact that they patted
him down he had no weapon they even the
body language between the officers and
mr. Brooks it was very casual very
informal nothing seemed to happen that
would indicate that he was of some
danger but you're right at the critical
point of the shooting what the evidence
shows that he was some 18 feet three
inches away his back was turned and and
I believe a reasonable person would
conclude that he was not an immediate
threat at that time yes sir
[Music]
well I have put together a list of nine
recommendations and I believe
recommendation number eight is is that
we are to eliminate both sovereign
immunity and qualified immunity for
cases involving police shootings we've
got to do it and you know my barometer
that says to me that something is wrong
with that immunity even our good friend
Clarence Thomas says something is wrong
with it and when Clarence Thomas says
that it's bad you know it's probably
pretty bad and so I think we need to
change that we need to change it so that
the families of victims like mrs. Miller
the way that the law stands right now
they don't stand a very good chance that
they decided to pursue some lawsuit it
ought to change for people all over the
country well what happens next is the
way that the law stands now we'll wait
for an indictment and as the of the
reporter pointed out we've already
scheduled about seven cases that are
scheduled to be presented to grand
jurors before this one so I would
suspect that we're probably talking
about January of February when we would
get a chance to present it to a grand
jury I believe that should be eliminated
I don't think we should wait because the
district attorney or why can't the
district attorney just sign the
indictment and let the case go forward
I have long given up predicting Superior
Court judges I do not know well as I
mentioned the list of the nine things
that I'm recommending one of the things
that I think we ought to do for the
whole country if there is a police force
there are 18,000 police departments in
the United States every one of them
ought to have a civil citizen review
board but I think the citizen review
board ought to be changed to require
that when the city does not follow the
recommendation of the review board that
failure to follow it ought to be signed
off by the mayor it ought to be signed
off by the police chief and it ought to
be signed off by the city attorney
because I know that with your board a
great many of the recommendations are
never followed and the citizens believe
what what's the use of having a board if
they never follow into the
recommendations and so I think it ought
to change for people all over the United
States and it's really kind of sad that
Atlanta is one of the only jurisdictions
in the entire United States with an
active civilian review board
to the DA's office yes yes so let me
take one more well they yeah well I'm
expected that he would do that and I'm
not surprised by that but we've already
interviewed him twice and so I can tell
you what he has said to us
I don't I stand by what we've said today
I think that is the reasonable
interpretation and and I think if there
is some litigation in court I think that
what we contend will be proven to be the
correct view of what happened thank you
all very much
yeah you want to get here so we're not
gonna get run over I got you